Puerto Rico, the island of Ricky Martin, Bad
Bunny, Daddy Yankee and piña coladas is also
known for its unusual political status: because
you see, Visual Politik viewers, this island
is not a state, but part an unincorporated
territory of the United States of America.
However, this could change very soon: Will
Puerto Rico become the 51st state of the United
States?
In this video we tell you all the details.
Its status is as unusual as it is controversial,
because Puerto Rico, despite being under US
sovereignty, does not participate in the vote
for president, nor does it vote for senators
or congressmen with voting rights.
Despite this, Puerto Ricans have time and
again ratified their desire to remain within
this scheme.
However, in recent years something has been
changing.
The question arises: Are Puerto Ricans ready
to take the next step?
Where is the island of enchantment headed?
Well, in this video we are going to tell you
all the details.
Let's get started.
Puerto Rico has become the largest economy
in the Caribbean and the standard of living
on this island is reasonably high.
Obviously being closely connected to the North
American giant has certain benefits.
And perhaps that is why both the government
and the islanders themselves have practically
never embarked on any independence venture.
They have always been very attached to their
Commonwealth regime.
However, the last few years have not been
easy and the model seems increasingly out
of date and is losing support: in the end,
Puerto Ricans are US citizens, yes, but they
have no real representation in Congress, they
do not vote for federal authorities and their
justice system is not entirely autonomous.
So in a way Puerto Rico is still a colony.
Perhaps that is why Puerto Ricans themselves
have said ENOUGH is enough, it is time to
move forward...
Not to move away from the United States, but
rather to fully integrate with the North American
giant.
And the question is, is this really possible,
and will we soon see Puerto Rico become the
51st state of the union?
What could such a change mean for the island?
Today, in this video we are going to answer
these questions, but before we do that, let’s
take a look at a little history to understand
where it all began.
Let's get into it.
FROM MADRID TO FORAKER AND JONES)
During his second voyage to the American continent,
Christopher Columbus came across the island
we all know today as Puerto Rico.
Its capital, San Juan, was so named, precisely,
in honor of Prince John, then Prince of Asturias
and heir to the throne of Castile and Aragon
in what is now Spain.
From that moment on and for more than 400
years, the Spanish crown maintained control
of the island until eventually a confrontation
between Spain and the United States changed
this relationship forever in the 19th century.
In 1895 the Cuban War broke out.
In this conflict, pro-independence revolutionary
rebels confronted the Spanish royalists.
The pressure for the Crown was increasing
and its position was more and more compromised.
To try to alleviate the situation and the
increasingly strong pro-independence sentiment,
Madrid recognized both Cuba and Puerto Rico
as autonomous regions in 1897.
However, it was not enough and, what’s more,
Uncle Sam's help ended up backing the rebels.
Finally, in 1898, a political-military clash
between Spain and the United States ended
with the resounding defeat of the old empire.
The peace agreement that was reached established
that Cuba would remain under American guardianship
while Puerto Rico, Guam and the Philippines
became direct colonial dependencies of the
United States.
For the first time the United States demonstrated
not only its strength, but above all its status
as a power and its ability to intervene abroad
to limit the influence of other foreign powers.
However, despite this, it was not entirely
clear what its relationship would be with
these new territories that it now had under
his control.
Let's just say that in Washington they didn't
want to emulate the old colonial scheme of
the Spanish or the British Empires.
[Which makes sense.
After all this country emerged as a reaction
against the very concept of colony].
Well, it was in 1900, when the then senator
from Ohio, Joseph B. Foraker, led the drafting
and approval of a law that bore his own surname,
the Foraker Act; a law that established the
new political scheme that would be applied
from that moment on in Puerto Rico.
For instance, this law determined that the
President of the United States himself would
appoint a governor for four years, who would
govern alongside an Executive Council in which
at least 5 of its 11 members would have to
be Puerto Ricans.
Simultaneously, a small local House of Delegates,
consisting of 35 members chosen by the local
population, began to function on the island.
For its part, the United States District Court
for Puerto Rico was created to manage the
island's judicial system, and an appeals process
to the US Supreme Court was established.
Also, despite not being a state, Puerto Ricans
would be able to elect a "Resident Commissioner,"
who would have a voice but no vote in the
US House of Representatives.
The stakes would be raised just 17 years later.
In 1917, the Jones-Shafroth Act, signed by
then-President Woodrow Wilson, struck a blow
with its Article 5.
Just take a look at it.
("All citizens of Puerto Rico [...] and all
natives of Puerto Rico who were temporarily
absent from the Island on 11 April 1899, and
have thereafter returned to and are permanently
residing in said island, and are not citizens
of any foreign country, are hereby declared
to be citizens of the United States, and shall
be considered and held as such.”
Jones-Shafroth Act (1917))
Suddenly, something very unusual for the time
was done: Puerto Ricans were recognized as
citizens of the United States.
An unprecedented privilege: Puerto Ricans
were not born in a formal US state, but nevertheless
enjoyed the same rights.
[By the way, have you noticed what year this
law was passed?
Well...
I say this because it is said that this initiative
had a lot to do with increasing the recruiting
base in the midst of World War One.
Of course, we can't know for sure if that
was the deciding factor.]
However, the Jones-Shafroth Act also created
a locally elected and much more representative
bicameral legislature, a chamber that became
competent to legislate on island affairs.
Of course, both the governor of the island
and even, if necessary, the President of the
United States had the right of veto.
The point is that, in only 17 years, Puerto
Ricans became US citizens and set in motion
the prototype of their civil government.
But what exactly is this island?
A colony?
A territory subordinate to the United States?
While it’s true that Puerto Ricans are US
citizens, the relationship of their land to
the rest of the country is quite different.
Listen up.
By the way, before we continue, if you are
someone who likes the world of economics,
don't forget to take a look at our new sister
channel: VisualEconomik.
We leave you the link in the description and
up here
COMMONW...
AH NO, UNINCORPORATED TERRITORY)
The government of Puerto Rico continued to
be elected from the Oval Office until 1947,
when Act 447 of the US Congress established
the possibility that the island's Governor
would finally be elected by the people themselves.
Thus Luis Muñoz Marín became the first governor
elected by Puerto Ricans.
His administration lasted no less than 16
years, and was absolutely key to the island's
status.
For example, in 1950, Muñoz Marín managed
to reach an agreement with Washington for
the approval of Act 600, which gave Puerto
Rico the possibility of having its own "state
constitution", as the rest of the states of
the Union already had.
It was a kind of fundamental law that established
the organization of the territory.
Well, in this text, which finally came into
force in 1952, it establishes that Puerto
Rico is itself a "Commonwealth" attached to
the United States, but since the text is also
written in Spanish, the translation speaks
of a "Freely Associated State", which is the
status that the island still holds officially
today...
This marked a turning point.
From that moment on, Muñoz Marín's own idea
was that Puerto Rico should have more and
more autonomy.
As you are about to see, this is essentially
the idea that modern Puerto Rico is founded
on and it defines its particular relationship
with the United States.
Take a look.
There will always be some areas of authority
that we will delegate which will be defense,
legislation inherent in common citizenship,
legislation inherent in common currency and
a few other things like that.
But the progress is that every day, as the
commonwealth grows, the votes that you and
all Puerto Ricans cast at the ballot box will
have greater authority over our lives.")
However, not everything was so harmonious.
In 1950 the Jayuya Uprising took place, a
revolt led by armed pro-independence sectors
that was quickly put down by the security
forces.
Let's just say that the whole free associated
State thing was not really apparent.
Be that as it may, in 1952, President Dwight
Eisenhower gave the go-ahead but demanded
that a referendum be held to ascertain the
true will of Puerto Ricans.
The elections were held on 4 November of that
same year.
And, do you want to know the result?
Well...
No less than 87.8% of the islanders voted
in favor of the new constitutional framework
establishing the commonwealth.
The support was, as you can see, overwhelming,
an absolute majority.
This would be one of the many referendums
in which Puerto Ricans have expressed their
support for maintaining ties with Washington:
We could almost say that the second half of
the 20th century was a kind of honeymoon period
between the continental United States and
Puerto Rico.
Look at this.
SANCHEZ VALLE, THE ARMS DEALER WHO CHANGED
HISTORY)
The second half of the 20th century was a
bed of roses for the Puerto Rican economy.
Around 1950, the US federal government introduced
a package of tax incentives for U.S. companies
to settle on the island, generating a huge
economic boom.
Look at the difference with the rest of Latin
America.Construction, hotels, businesses,
new highways...
Puerto Rico's economy began to flourish.
And of course this had significant social
implications: poverty was reduced and practically
all parameters improved.
For years Puerto Rico was considered a success
story.
And take note, because since the first referendum
was held in 1952, Puerto Ricans have been
called to the polls six times to express their
opinion on the sovereignty status of the island.
They did so in 1967, 1993, 1998, 2012, 2017
and 2020.
Well, in all these public surveys, the link
with Washington won...
But in different ways.
While the commonwealth concept won until 2012,
as of that year, the option in favor of becoming
another state, a formal state of the United
States, gained a clear majority.
And the question is, what caused such a leap?
Why did Puerto Ricans cease to be satisfied
with their current status?
Well, in order to answer that question we
have to go back to September 2008, when Luis
Sanchez del Valle was captured on the island
for illegal arms trafficking.
He was simultaneously indicted on that charge
by both the US and Puerto Rican courts.
The defendant then sued the State of the island
by declaring that a person could not be charged
twice for the same crime in the same jurisdiction,
thus framing the renowned case Puerto Rico
v. Sanchez Valle, which was resolved in 2015
with a controversial ruling:
C1("Puerto Rico's authority to prosecute persons
derives from delegation by the United States
Congress and not by virtue of any sovereignty
of its own (...) The adoption of a constitution,
by delegation of Congress, to organize local
government in substitution for much of the
organic law then in force, did not represent
a cession of sovereignty to Puerto Rico.
To the contrary, Puerto Rico did not cease
to be a territory of the United States."
Puerto Rico Supreme Court Doctrine)
And you may be wondering, so what is so controversial
about this?
Basically, the courts made it clear that the
sovereignty of Puerto Rico does not rest with
Puerto Ricans, but rather remains in the hands
of Washington.
Over the years, this concept, along with economic
problems that we have already told you about
in past videos, suddenly triggered the ambition
to change Puerto Rico's status.
In 2017, for example, the island was practically
bankrupt with an external debt in excess of
$70 billion.
In fact it was not until January 2022 that
a federally appointed financial oversight
committee managed to restructure the public
debt with creditors.
But, of course, there is still a long way
to go before the problem can be considered
solved.
But, do you know what is most curious of all?
The funny thing is that many of Puerto Rico's
economic problems, if not the vast majority,
have nothing to do with being a Commonwealth
or the 51st state.
We're talking about things like the Jones
Merchant Marine Act passed in 1920 and still
in effect today.
This is a law that prohibits foreign-flagged
ships from transporting goods between two
US ports.
This makes moving things to and from Puerto
Rico very expensive... which obviously erodes
a lot of the island's competitiveness.
Why is that?
Well because US flagged and crewed ships are
much, much more expensive to operate.
As an example, this law makes it impossible
for large international freighters to unload
goods destined for Puerto Rico on their way
to or from the US.
Instead those goods have to make a much more
convoluted journey to get to the island.
Imagine, Shanghai-Texas, reload goods onto
a US-flagged ship, Texas-Puerto Rico.
And then we also need to talk about things
like the minimum wage and federal subsidy
plans.
But in order to understand this, look at this
chart.
As you can see, Puerto Rico is much, much
poorer than the rest of the United States.
However, since it has to apply the same federal
minimum wage or an abnormally high level of
social benefits in relation to what the parameters
of the island actually are.
And here the problem is evident.
What is acceptable for Texas does not have
to be the same for Puerto Rico.
You could say that federal policies and regulations
mean that when it comes down to it, very few
people work in Puerto Rico.
That is one of the main problems.
Although, yes it’s true that things are
improving thanks to new tax incentives for
companies setting up on the island.
Well, when it comes down to it, the fact is
that none of these problems would change if
Puerto Rico ceases to be a commonwealth and
becomes just another US state.
In fact, some of its tax benefits for businesses
and investors could disappear altogether.
Yes, the island would gain more integration,
influence and probably government investment...
But it would leave many other things by the
wayside.
Be that as it may, the option of becoming
another state is the number one favorite of
Puerto Ricans.
Take a look.
THE STATUS THAT WENT OUT OF FASHION)
In 2020, Puerto Rico held its latest referendum,
but this time neither commonwealth nor independence
was an option.
The question was much clearer: "Should Puerto
Rico be admitted immediately into the Union
as a state?"
This is exactly the question that was asked
in that referendum.
Well, the yes vote obtained more than 50%
of the votes, which gave the island's government
the strength to lobby in Washington.
It was a campaign in which the current governor,
Pedro Pierluisi, is involved, but which requires
overcoming a very complicated legislative
circuit.
For example, the House of Representatives
must pass a law that enables a binding referendum
for the federal government, that is, an election
that not only allows citizens to express their
opinion – as has been the case up to now
– but also has legal and political consequences
that allow the President of the United States
to sign the incorporation of the new state.
Well, in December 2022, with 233 votes in
favor and 191 against, the Lower House surprisingly
succeeded in passing House Bill 8393.
The first step was thus completed, but there
is still the Senate...
And that, VisualPolitik community, is not
exactly a piece of cake.
Why?
Well, basically because Puerto Rico is a very
democratic territory politically.
In other words, many Republicans are afraid
that what already happened with Hawaii will
happen again, that Puerto Rico will be a Democratic
stronghold that will swing the majority in
the chambers, particularly, in the non-proportional
Senate, where all states, regardless of their
size or population, have two representatives.
C2("We have to go senator by senator explaining
to them why it is fair to give equal rights
to American citizens residing in Puerto Rico.
We also have to explain to them that Puerto
Rico is diverse, that neither should Republican
senators think that if Puerto Rico becomes
a state automatically that means that there
will be 2 senators and 4 Democratic congressmen."
Pedro Pierluisi, Governor of Puerto Rico)
So the whole thing seems complicated.
But who knows.
In any case, the Puerto Rican government has
already set 5 November 2023 as the date for
a new referendum, hoping that by then the
Senate will have given the green light and
these elections can be the final step to becoming
the 51st star on the American flag.
Or at least the 51st state, because it seems
that the flag will not be changed.
We will see what impact there will be among
Puerto Ricans if the legislature closes the
doors again.
But for now it's your turn:
Do you think Puerto Rico should become a new
state?
What benefits would this option have?
What do you think about the commonwealth status?
Leave us your comments here and if you found
this video interesting don't forget to like
and subscribe to VisualPolitik.
Thank you very much for being there.
All the best and see you next time.